les yvelines terre de cinéma terre de
talents du septième art aussi isabelle
huppert jacques tati guillaume canet
bérénice bejo ou encore l'oscarisé jean
dujardin
tous sont nés sont passés où ont vécu
dans le département la liste de ses
acteurs et réalisateurs est très longue
et non exhaustive et malgré une carrière
remplie certains n'oublient pas leurs
racines que ce soit le trappistes omar
sied pour la présentation d'un film à
saint quentin où le réalisateur eric
toledano intervenant dans son ancien
collège à versailles
il leur arrive parfois de revenir sur
leur territoire
passage au bizet passage porte bonheur
de venir à skagway c'est le cinéma où je
joue je venais quand je veux sécher les
cours
il ya mon lycée qui est juste devant
donc c'est une forme de pèlerinage quoi
j'ai grandi à versailles et alors si on
est constitué de la ville d'où l'on
vient
les expériences à l'intérieur de cette
ville le collège c'est quand même une
période très structurante dans la vie
poutine il ya un nouveau collègue pour
toi ma soi disant enfermés pour atteinte
à l'intégrité physique d'un groupe de
personne alors qu'en fait c'est juste
une agression à la grenade
lui aussi est originaire de versailles
et à la cote en ce moment alban ivanov
fait cette année à la fiche d'une
dizaine de films à l'instar de jamel
debbouze et 2 mars si sa carrière a
débuté dans l'humour avant de se
poursuivre sur grand écran
moi j'ai voulu commencer acteurs mais ça
marchait pas il voudra à l'époque et
c'est ce qui fait que je me suis dirigé
vers la scène et le one man show
d'accord parce que j'en avais marre
d'attendre qu'on m'appelle pour le
cinéma etc c'est ça et c'est en fait
c'est une fois que j'ai fait le deuil du
cinéma et je me suis vraiment mis à fond
dans la seine
le cinéma commencé à s'intéresser à vous
mais dans les yvelines aussi de jeunes
talents depuis plusieurs années le
réalisateur quentin du puits seront au
festival de cannes pour vendre ses
productions
à 29 ans le plaisir hu a déjà une
quinzaine de réalisations à son actif
raconter des histoires c'est ce qui a
poussé ce fan de george lucas c'est
ridley scott à faire du cinéma
faire un film c'est très long soit un
court métrage une publicité où
évidemment un long métrage mais tout
prend du temps et il ya beaucoup de
joueurs qui sont difficiles où on peut
douter comme dans beaucoup de métiers
donc il faut avoir cette passion-là pour
réussir à traverser joie qui sont
difficiles on voit pas forcément
l'objectif ont pas forcément le film
fini on va pas forcément le projet fini
et solidaire au bout du chemin il y a le
film il ya l'histoire qu'on veut
raconter qu'on veut montrer aux gens
après avoir tourné une publicité au
château de grousset cet été quand un
dupuis s'attelle à un autre projet la
réalisation d'un documentaire sur yacine
haddad un boxeur de sa salle de sport à
nos repas cette envié de montre un peu
l'envers du décor de montrer ce que
c'est qu'aujourd'hui quatre
professionnels de la boxe en france est
de montrer malgré le fait que yacine
soient professionnels tous les
sacrifices que ça représente de devoir
travailler à côté de cas longtemps
prouvé celles qui ne peut pas vivre
aujourd'hui de ton sport par exemple
l'avenir du réalisateur est fait de
longs métrages trois sont en projet pour
rêver pourquoi pas d'être un jour
reconnu par ses pairs
[Musique]